l'onu remettra demain un rapport
alarmant sur le réchauffement de la
planète ce n'est pas la première fois
mais les chiffres inquiètent de plus en
plus en effet durant le prochain siècle
la température de la planète pourrait
augmenter de 6 degrés avec des
conséquences sur l'environnement est
tout simplement sur la vie des hommes
olivet szatmary l'europe n'avait jamais
connu ça des inondations à répétition
des tempêtes violentes de plus en plus
fréquentes ou des étés torrides en dix
ans la terre a connu les plus importants
bouleversements climatiques jamais
observée par les scientifiques
le réchauffement de la planète semble
bien avoir des conséquences directes sur
le climat après une semaine de travail
en commun genève le groupe des experts
de l'onu tire la sonnette d'alarmé
d'après leurs conclusions la température
moyenne de la planète à déjà variée
d'hommes demi degré depuis le 19e siècle
ce réchauffement pourrait augmenter d'un
an et demi à 6 degrés au cours du
prochain siècle si rien n'est fait mais
battles devons faire une meilleure
utilisation des énergies disponibles
il ne s'agit pas attenter à notre santé
ça ne veut pas dire revenir en arrière
non plus seulement faire une meilleure
utilisation hors d importantes
ressources tronçon recèle la planète
bleue
dans leur rapport les experts sont
affirmatifs l'accroissement les
températures est bien lié à l'activité
humaine et notamment aux milliards de
tonnes de dioxyde de carbone rejeté dans
l'atmosphère
les conséquences sont déjà dramatique
sur la faune et la flore ici en alaska
des insectes alors méconnu dans ces
régions s'attaque aux forêts certaines
parties de la forêt ont été détruite à
90 et en disant nous avons eu plus de
ravages qu'au cours des 60 dernières
années et on peut dire que tout ceci est
dû à l'augmentation de la température en
alaska
autres conséquences liées au
réchauffement la fonte des glaces
notamment aux pôles
un phénomène qui entraîne une élévation
du niveau des océans d'ici quelques
siècles des archipels ou encore la
camargue pourrait bien disparaître sous
les eaux